make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay
so we are getting caught up on excalibur
and uh
and it's been a little while since we
covered this right i feel like we need
to get caught up on everything going on
with the x-men and all that kind of
stuff i meant to get caught back up on
it but then i forgot and like other
stuff was going on and i was like okay
so like we'll cover that stuff and i
kept meaning to come back and it kept
getting postponed so we'll also cover
the marauders
and then i think we need to finish what
are the ones we need to finish
i think we need to finish uh fallen
angels
and i thought we were caught up on new
mutants maybe we're not i'll have to
double check uh but
we end up picking up here with basically
like jubilee and and what's
effectively the excalibur team uh
showing up at the
at buckingham house now remember they
were invited here by the queen
right that's where we left off on the
last video that we had pete wisdom who
was sent as a as an emissary more or
less from britain to betsy braddock to
jubilee to
to uh gambit and so on in order to bring
them to uh
to buckingham palace so a conversation
could be had between betsy braddock and
the queen and the reason why
is because with brian braddock more or
less missing right people don't you know
unless you're part of the the core team
you don't really know where he is and
betsy brady taking his place
britain as a whole seemed to be seemed
to revoke the idea soon to rebuke the
idea that betsy braddock was captain
britain right you know britain had come
to believe or
come to see brian braddock as captain
britain it's the character they were
used to and so the result of that is
because of the fact that betsy's taken
his place the question is where's brian
bring him back right you know in a lot
of ways it was kind of the kind of a
i guess an allegory to like fan
sentiment to a degree but
you end up having a fight that breaks
out between like gambit and the people
who are here right because
as we know for the most part in addition
to everything going on here with the
arts to excalibur with the formation of
the mutant nation of krakowa a lot of
humans out there are still fearful of
the mutant population right they see the
formation of cocoa as mutants
consolidating their numbers for the
purpose of like going to war with
humanity right so a lot of people are
scared and so you end up having somebody
who throws a bottle at a throws a bottle
of gambit and then suddenly they're met
with the the one thing they didn't
expect
consequences for their actions and so
this leads to gambit basically losing
his mind
and attacking these people to help them
understand their place in their bigger
picture now the downside to this is it
kind of continues the impression that
mutants are a credible threat right so
just kind of give you guys perspective
here uh humanity's afraid of mutants for
reasons they don't really even
understand themselves
somebody freaks out throws a bottle of
gambit he in turn attacks them and now
they're more afraid of mutants than they
were before right so
that's kind of what happened uh but of
course this leads to betsy basically
calling gambit off and the two of them
end up sort of going forward from there
right they actually go or i guess really
the group
uh more or less ends up kind of kind of
coalescing and the reason why this
matters is because they all basically
sort of meet back up again you know of
course with apocalypse there and
everything else and the important thing
to understand here is that apocalypse
kind of seems to have his plan going on
in the background we don't really know
what it is
but he really begins to kind of split
the various individuals of the team off
now an important thing to understand
here is this happens for a couple
different reasons
the first reason is because of the fact
that apocalypse is exceedingly old so he
just
knows stuff i mean you can't be five
five or six thousand years old and like
not know stuff right so people kind of
look to him to a degree it's like okay
if this guy says something needs to be
done then he probably knows what he's
talking about
the other part of this is that
apocalypse is part of the quiet council
and the quiet council as we know is
basically the the council that leads
krakowa and so to receive an order from
apocalypse is to basically receive an
order from the leader of the mutant
population right so even if only for
that reason
they more or less kind of have to follow
it and so what he basically ends up
doing
is splitting groups off right he starts
splitting things up he basically tells
pete wisdom and betsy braddock that of
course they basically need to go
together in order for bessie to attend
her meeting with the queen and then he
tasks
richter who of course can control the
earth and gambit with going into the
earth and capturing some particular
crystals now with gambit and richter
once they get down here they're
immediately met by the arrival of druids
now we talked about them before
druids are in a lot of ways minor
characters and comics in this day and
age back in like the 70s and the 80s
really more so the 70s than the 80s and
even if you go way back in like the
1940s uh in when it was
timely comics before it became atlas and
before it became marvel the druids were
really more prominent characters right i
wouldn't really say prominent they
probably had more stories told about
them
but basically druids are individuals who
reside inside the earth so they're
similar to the to the deviants in that
way except of course their origin is not
the same as the deviants and of course
they don't look the same uh basically
it's one of these things where they're
they've you know
where richter and gambit have been
tasked with entering the realm of the
druids and stealing these crystals
stealing particular crystals now once
they locate them of course kind of
fleeing and dodging the druids
druids where they can the druids finally
catch up to them and when they come
across
when they come across richter they
recognize him as somebody with control
over the earth and so they kind of see
him as somebody unto himself right so to
give you guys some perspective here
if we looked at like the world of avatar
the last airbender
and we said okay you've got like the the
fire kingdom or
or whatever it's called an avatar i
don't know it doesn't matter but like
you've got the you got the
people can do fire right you've got that
section of the world
the fire kingdom no fire
nation fire nation earth kingdom
yes and then and then what's the leader
of the fire kingdom called
what's what's that it's the or the fire
nation rather what's the leader of the
fire nation called
the fire the fire lord okay
so the fire king okay so so
mariah's an enormous fan of avatar right
like
she lives and dies here's the funniest
thing she finished watching it on amazon
right when it was announced on right
when it came out on netflix and then
turned around and watched it again
and i was like what's the difference is
it like extra scenes or something she's
like no i saw netflix this time i'm like
what even what even senses that make
right so okay so so
so to go back to our example gordon you
got to keep all that in
to go back to our example you've got
you've got the fire kingdom and you've
got the the fire king
and what you have here is let's say for
example like all the people most for the
most part everybody who can bend fire
lives within that kingdom right but
let's say that like somewhere that's not
even part of the other kingdoms right
just
a place out there somewhere a person's
born with the ability to bend fire
that's more or less what this is with
richter that the druids see themselves
as as people who can control the world
or i'm sorry control the earth itself
and as such
are their own community and recognizing
that richter can do that they basically
consider him
one of their own now richter more or
less rejects it not not in really like
an egregious way right he's like i don't
want to have anything to do with you
crazy bums down here on the ground
talking about the ability to bend earth
that's not really what he's referring to
but it's just one of these things of
like
this isn't really my home man like i'm
sure you guys are cool but like you know
this ain't my thing plus like you guys
don't have wi-fi so like
the the result of this is that they
basically reveal that the crystals that
were here
that gambit and richter were going to
make off with were there to be a
distraction right the energy contained
within them had long since been depleted
right that they were there to just
distract people and so ultimately they
end up handing
handing crystals a couple of the
crystals over to richter and then
following that they basically kind of
try to banish gambit where they use
their ability to control the ground to
seemingly destroy gambit
right just kind of send him follow you
know plummeting to his death and of
course richter jumps after him in an
effort to try to save him now
this is where things get pretty
interesting because of course we end up
picking up with the covenant cabba and
with betsy braddock and pete wisdom now
the idea behind this and really betsy's
instructions from the queen was to meet
with the covenant cabba and get things
sorted out a little bit of an
explanation here the word acaba
is probably familiar to a lot of you
guys who've been reading marvel comics
for a long time
especially with regards to apocalypse
and the reason why is because apocalypse
was basically raised by the the
sandstormers
you know from that were led by ball
which is where he developed his
philosophy of the
survival of the fittest things like that
but he was abandoned by the clan akava
now the clan of cabba and the covenant
kabba
are not the same thing the argument
that's presented here is that the coven
acaba
basically hails from humans who existed
in this in the the town or the
province of a kaaba that existed inside
of egypt but the idea here
is that any time they had anybody who
was born to them that looked like they
were a bad omen essentially like
apocalypse did they would kill him in
that instance they just left apocalypse
to die
in the to die in the the harsh sun but
basically they were the they were the
the group not these individuals here but
the the covenant cabba
was the coven that basically ended up
giving birth to apocalypse so i guess
in that way they're similar i mean the
coven is a modern day iteration
of what the acaba people used to be back
in the day so i guess the logical
extension right the logical uh you know
the logical
line of succession you know generation
after generation
basically but the other important thing
to pick up here is that they were
designed to be a distraction and the
reason why
is because what the covenant cabba is
trying to do is discredit betsy
braddock right to basically put her in a
situation to where the queen would
actively ask her to step down now
i'm not super knowledgeable about the
role the queen plays in england and a
lot of you guys who are fans from across
the pond you can probably give some much
better insight in the comments section
but as i understand it
the queen while she does have power i
think is really kind of revered as a
figurehead in britain and so the results
of that is that if the queen were to ask
uh ask betsy braddock to stand up to
step down because of the enormous
respect that the citizens of britain
have of the queen and the royal family
then she would say yes she would most
likely say okay i'll step down
and then good luck to you man because
whatever happens happens you know and
then there's and then kind of
kind of go from there but the other
thing that we end up finding out here is
that when the the child of jubilee who's
basically a dragon
more or less can can turn into a dragon
was taken to otherworld and then
breathed dragonfire what it did is it
began to diminish the barriers between
otherworld and the main marvel universe
and what this has done is
has allowed these sort of fictional
beings right griffins and hydras and so
on to pass from other world
into the main marvel universe and so
what this means is that this is a
this is kind of a scenario where it all
kind of seems to have been engineered by
the covenant cabba
alongside morgan le faye for the purpose
of basically making it look like the new
captain britain is totally inept that
betsy braddock is no ryan braddock and
that
basically things need to go back to the
way they used to be and so that's where
you kind of have this scenario where in
the midst of all this an apocalypse
talking to rogue that rogue suddenly
wakes up now
with with gambit and richter we kind of
jump back to there for a second it's
pretty straightforward right in this
little tidbit in the sense that richter
basically uses one of the one of the
crystals in order to kind of siphon its
power to bolster his own and then
basically save gambit and once they get
back to the surface of course they find
all these
sort of you know mythical beings and
monsters and so on that are just
ripping everything up and that basically
leads to this this interesting little
dream sequence now for betsy braddock
herself and even for the other other
members of excalibur right for
for uh apocalypse and for jubilee
they're all basically trying to fight
off these monsters as best they can
but for rogue herself in this dream
sequence that she's in which up to this
point we didn't really know what she was
seeing but in the stream sequence she's
in she's suddenly met by the arrival of
a burning dog and and what ends up
happening is she's kind of led to what
looks like stonehenge off in the
distance only for it to basically be the
heads of various sentinels right
and of course apocalypse ends up
manifesting and it's almost kind of like
this this fear factor right
there's this this kind of tug in the
mind of jubilee that something's wrong
that gambit needs her help right the
gamut's basically going to fall but the
important thing here
is that with richter showing back up
with gambit showing back up and so on
you have this massive fight there's
this conflict that breaks out between
gambit and rogue and the reason why
is because apocalypse has been planning
all of this seemingly for thousands of
years right moving these pieces around
the board different things like that now
i don't know if he's been actively
planning it or if it was a plan that he
came up with and then looked around to
see if it would work and realize that
all the pieces were more or less in play
but the important thing to grasp here is
that there are two things going on the
first
is that gambit traveling back to this
location with richter had come across a
few telepaths and he had asked one of
them to basically tap into the mind of
rogue right to kind of give her a nudge
and push her in the direction of waking
up the responsive apocalypse is
you've potentially screwed up this
entire plant the whole idea was that
rogue had to kind of wake up on her own
and i'm expecting these
things to happen a certain way because
it's been planned that way your actions
here your meddling have potentially
screwed all this up i have potentially
destroyed everything that i've been
working on in order to try to try to
pull off this whole this whole scenario
and so it leads to a massive conflict
between apocalypse and gambit now
gambit's really just kind of fighting
out of frustration an apocalypse takes
him out
like that right he literally just grabs
him and smashes his head into the ground
and knocks him unconscious
the other part of this is that where he
was looking to basically use these
crystals to kind of activate this uh
this this portal
that suddenly you end up finding out one
of the crystals is drained and that that
crystal that was drained was used by
richter when he saved when he saved
gambit and so for the most part
apocalypse is pissed because the whole
mission has basically just been scrapped
right like
everything he's been working on has been
screwed up and he even and he even makes
a comment about that right he says ten
thousand year old bones
which is basically what what powers
these crystals right where they get
their energy from but he says ten
thousand year old bones
gone in an accident to save a vagabond
right like that's it's like
all this came crashing down because a
thief was
basically fell off a cliff like this
sucks right he's he's mad but he's like
maybe what i need is here and you right
so he considers the idea of
killing gambit in order to achieve his
in order to achieve his goal now one of
the things to kind of remember here is
that death doesn't really exist anymore
for the x-men right they can always be
resurrected
when that will happen depends because
you've got a resurrection queue where
you've got
people who are expected to be
resurrected at certain times and
depending on your level of significance
you can be resurrected earlier or you
can be resurrected last but of course at
this point
rogue basically wakes up and when that
happens she immediately lashes out right
at the fact that that apocalypse had
knocked out gambit and was potentially
intending to kill him in order to
complete the ritual and so rogue freaks
out
rogue attacks apocalypse now when that
happens she immediately sees his control
and this is something that we've
never seen happen in marvel comics we've
never ever seen an instance
where rogue takes the power of
apocalypse we saw it to a degree not we
didn't really see it in actually the
animated series it was the uh it was the
power of of
um of warren worthington when he was a
horseman but we've never seen that
happen before but basically she siphons
off
all the life energy of apocalypse and he
actually even goads her into doing it
right so it's like you have to do this
but he siphons off all the life energy
of apocalypse and basically kills him
and like when that happens the ritual is
more or less complete now right because
rogue can touch this portal she can
activate it and using the power of
apocalypse combined with her own innate
abilities
survive the whole experience right
that's what knocked her out in the first
place and so then of course you
basically switch over to apocalypse
being resurrected and of course jamie
braddock the
really reality warping brother of betsy
and brian braddock is the one that helps
him along the way and so ultimately
you know jamie's like hey man like do
you still need me in this plan and the
response of apocalypse
is yes like i need you as part of this
plan now and so what we have now is
apocalypse combined with a reality
warper who we're moving towards
excalibur right who are moving towards
uh moving towards britain and that's
when things start to get wild because
when this happens and and when the
portal and everything's activated it
allows excalibur to basically pass
through
into other worlds right to directly
confront morgan le faye now morgan le
fay again
is basically the one kind of running
this show that morgan left was perfectly
content
existing in other world and just ruling
over camelot you know with the vanishing
of king arthur right nobody knows where
he is but she was perfectly content just
ruling over
camelot and avalon and just being there
right just being the one running the
show it wasn't until the mutants started
creating their cochon gates and because
of the fact that jamie braddock is a
mutant that has the ability to warp
reality and because of the fact that the
braddock family line
operates within the realm of otherworld
that a gate was created to access
otherworld that then morgan left started
freaking out that's why she's been
calling mutants witch breed
and so with that being the case she in
turn took offense to that and that's why
all of this has happened right she was
working alongside the covenant caba in
order to try to fight and destroy the
mutant population or at least to
destroy this cricoid gate and just
basically send a message saying do not
make gates that basically give you
access to like other world right
do not do that but when you've got
captain britain showing up here you've
got rogue you've got apocalypse who's
now been resurrected and makes his
return that basically what ends up
happening is he kind of calls a
ceasefire here's what we're going to do
all right what we're going to do here
is we are going to basically have a
contest
the whole point of what i've been doing
up to this point with regards to the
crystals and all that kind of stuff was
that when rogue woke up that rogue would
in turn be able to touch the portal and
allow us
entrance through the portal in order to
bring it into you morgan le faye but in
order to like end your rule and allow us
to place a mutant or a place what yeah
place one of our mutants in your
location
such as it was when rogue touched the
portal she collapsed right and that's
when all hell started to break loose
that's when you sent your forces to us
and that's where this whole conflict's
been going on ever since right so if we
kind of
leave out everything that's happened
between issues one and this one then
this is what was supposed to have
happened right this is what was supposed
to have taken place how the conflict
would have happened would have been
different but the idea here is that he
basically says
one of your forces against one of mine
your champion prize here
is basically brian braddock who's
operating under your control
he will fight my champion which is betsy
braddock and
it's kind of nuts because you initially
have morgan le faye who's kind of like
he's going to kill her and apocalypse
says and we will resurrect her and then
morgan lafaye gives one of like the
coolest lines ever she says okay
then he will fight then he will fight
like one whose life is precious to him
and she will fight like one whose life
is cheap
it's cool because what it basically
means is that if betsy braddock knows
that she can be resurrected from the
dead she won't truly give it her all
because subconsciously
she'll know no matter what happens i'll
survive this whereas if you have brian
braddock under the control of of
of morgan le faye who knows that if he
loses he's going to die then he'll fight
with everything he has right because at
that point he's fighting to live
right there are no second chances it's a
cool thing and so when the contest
begins you've basically got uh betsy
facing off against brian
and and betsy doesn't want to kill him
right she's like i don't i do not want
to do this like i do not want to kill
you i want you to live right like like
find a way to free yourself from her
control
now initially you had uh jubilee who
almost wanted to get involved right but
apocalypse basically says no no no you
have to stop we're going to need this
later on but for right now
you cannot interfere with this duel you
cannot you cannot have any involvement
there you have to let them fight
because whoever it is that wins this has
to win honorably and has to win
of their own accord otherwise the result
of the battle will be contested
it has to be that they won on their own
right and so that's what ends up
happening at least to a degree that's
what
seems to end up happening right that
what you have is the two of them
fighting betsy braddock basically gets
the upper hand on brian and then
in turn brian appears to basically die
from his own sword
and the implication and it's not
explicitly stated but the indication
here
is that jamie braddock used his ability
to manipulate reality to ensure that
betsy braddock won right just
a small little reality manipulating
nudge that led to betsy braddock
basically impaling
brian or him falling on a sword or
whatever it is that you want to call it
but from there
because of the fact that betsy seems to
have won through legitimate means of
course
shogo's fire breath opens fire basically
you know sends these
sends the forces of morgan lafaye into
retreat and then from there the question
of
morgan is well now what an apocalypse
says like you are now going to live in
exile
jamie braddock actually makes his powers
and she's just kind of left in a prison
right she's literally put in this cell
and then from there jimmy braddock is
basically instructed by
by betsy to resurrect brian and so all
of this was the working of apocalypse
all of this was planned by him
the idea that it would all basically
work out in the end and that's one of
the reasons why apocalypse becoming a
good guy
is actually so cool whenever we think
about the the the plans of apocalypse
they're always nefarious right they're
always
plans of him performing evil deeds but
more so than that apocalypse was never
really written as a character
that would have these grand plans that
would stretch on for hundreds if not
thousands of years and they would come
to fruition at some point in time right
apocalypse was always kind of written as
a villain who would just come up with
this plan all of a sudden and then like
use this horseman to try to see if it
could be achieved and then his horsemen
would fail then he would just give up
and it's kind of interesting because
under any normal circumstance apocalypse
could just kind of obliterate virtually
anybody right shy of like jimmy braddock
who can warp reality or some other
reality warping character like franklin
richards aside from something like that
apocalypse can defeat pretty much
anybody on earth and so with that being
the case the conflict is more or less
settled down right jamie braddock will
basically be the ruler of avalon he'll
replace morgan le faye and so the mutant
population now has one of their own
ruling other world you see how this
expansion is taking place
mutants are positioning their own kind
in places of power
in strategic locations now all of this
seems to really continue to point to
what we saw in house and powers of x the
reason why the mutants failed in their
war against the
the man and machine armies is because
they just weren't planning big enough
what this does is seem to expand all
that right because now with jamie
braddock running the show the mutant
population has control over the armies
of camelot they've got control over all
the magical beasts who are there they've
got a colossal army so it's like if
doctor strange wanted to bring in
virtually every magical being he could
possibly
think of in a fight against the avengers
who's gonna win there and that's where
things are kind of crazy because you
basically end up having
having this this this scenario where you
have jaime i'm sorry
you have betsy and you have brian who
are having a conversation with each
other right you know when everything
kind of settles
brian basically says that merlin and
roma who are the ones that originally
offered him the opportunity to become
captain britain they appeared to him in
a dream
and they off they they asked him to make
the choice the sword of might or the
amulet of right but because of the fact
that he was so filled with anger and
rage over the fact that that he was
basically
taken by morgan le faye and made into an
and into a henchman of hers that he
basically chose the sword of might and
he believes he failed he believes he
failed the test the reality is that he
didn't right he just
chose the sword of mind that's really
all that's really all that it comes down
to
and so ultimately when betsy basically
says well then i'll give you the amulet
back i will give you that emulate back
and you can go forward from there his
response is
no and when she offers another one and
saying then just don the sword of might
he says no because if i don the sword of
might then i'm basically just a captain
britain with a sword instead of an
amulet but people will see
that see me as captain britain and they
will they will shun you they will say
brian braddock is now back as captain
britain betsy braddock go away people
will turn on you
and they'll see you as a pretender more
so than they do right now and so i can't
do that because ultimately
people will know that i'm there and so
what she basically ends up saying is
then fine we won't tell people
take the sword become captain britain
become become the captain britain with a
sword of might
become that guy and we'll do the best we
can to make sure the world doesn't know
but if it does find out then who cares
right they're not gonna be able to split
us up we can stand against anything
right like we're twins we can stand
against anything the world has to offer
and so it's a cool moment it's it's a
really really cool idea here so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comments explain make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you